[Music]
from
uh japan comes what's probably not the
best introduction to anime but if you're
already a fan
wipe that pocky dust off on your wall
scroll and get your hands on
demon slayer kimetsu no yaiba the movie
mugen train the dubbed virgin but don't
worry
we wash it with subs too promise
check out the anime sensation that
everyone in their husbando bought a
ticket for
that not only saved the japanese box
office but had the biggest u.s opening
for a foreign film ever
and confused that of anyone who wandered
in to see what the fuss was about
though to be fair that's like making age
of ultron your first marvel movie
okay see thor's using his magic dream
jacuzzi to recover a vision of the
infinity stones
and you know what never mind just just
watch the punching
hop aboard the mugen train a direct
continuation of the demon slayer series
so it will not slow down to explain who
this veiny narrator is
why the hero keeps a small child gagged
in his backpack or why his friend looks
like the cover of a romance novel
written by pigs
i'm wearing the hide of the mountain god
on my head
oh he's just a guy wearing a severed
borehead that makes more sense
very slightly more sense but series fans
will instantly recognize this colorful
cast of characters
like zenitsu a pikachu you'll want to
slap instead of hog
in nosuke the series on sunday which is
the anime term for
more than one character trait oh and
tanjiro
the saintly protagonist literally a
perfect human
great kid and you just know he makes
sure to smell nice too
his scent is overwhelming but i can
smell him just barely
there's a faint scent of demon on it too
the demon sin is getting stronger by the
moment
he smells the most like kibutsuji i
could smell that nesuko's hurt
and i can smell he has a strong sense of
justice together they'll board a train
full of powerless losers who don't even
have a cool haircut so you can safely
ignore them
and team up with rengoku a samurai guy
fieri who's become one with the flame
broiler
and now runs the toughest dojo in flavor
town he's ultra powerful
pure-hearted and loves to eat tasty
so if it helps your memory to just call
him goku i say roll with it
are there demons to slay aboard this
mugen train i'm gonna level with you
there are there are several like enmu
a demon with the power to put the
audience to sleep with hour-long dream
sequences
who rides the line between upsetting and
hilarious by having sick frightened
children do all of his dirty work
nap time orphans then just when you
think the mugen train has fully gone off
the rails
middle management demon akuza shows up
with a burning desire
to [ __ ] goku i mean seducer and goku
i mean fight ring goku yeah fight
that's what he wants to do i can tell
just by looking at you that you're
strong
we could spar with each other endlessly
what a magnificent attack
such skills movement what unbelievable
strength that ironclad stance
those reflexes brilliant you haven't
reached your pbs
keep your eyes on me we'd be able to
each other for the rest of eternity
kiss kiss kiss so don't worry if you get
lost
because you can get the gist of demon
slayer if you've seen any other shonen
anime
the good guys have the big eyes and neon
clothes the bad guys are all pale pretty
boys and or tentacles
they're some kind of rigid power level
hierarchy was it really an upper-ranked
demon
everyone screams the names of their
attacks out loud
blazing universe there's always a secret
reserve of power you can unlock on the
brink of defeat
and the predictable death of the
protagonist's mentor that still somehow
works cause damn if goku doesn't go down
like a champ
what a fighter even made his mom proud
he's just so noble
i'm not crying you're crying everyone's
crying
even that bird is crying wait why is
that bird crying
so get ready for one anime-ass anime and
if you have a tolerance for that sort of
thing
this is one of the better ones because
it looks absolutely amazing
most of the humor survives the cultural
gap and there's an extended sequence
where the hero learns to quickly chop
his own head off in his dreams to wake
up long enough to jump the head off a
demon train
and get saved from accidentally chopping
his head off for real by a friend who
wears the chopped off head of the boy
who raised him
never change enemy never change
starring rash ketchum
anxiety charlotte's weed
what's in the box what's in the box
lionel and
demon the tank engine's big adventure
you want to bet on a naked boar man
fighting a psychic child in his dreams
mugen train
the seaweed is always greener in
somebody else's lake
silencio bruno a really dumb movie
about really dumb people doing really
dumb things
for really dumb reasons let's make a
mess
and get out of here